howdy Richard a were you from hi I'm
Christina Christina thanks we're excited
thank you guys for being here I've seen
you in your dad several times it's the
first love event with you guys my
question is actually a combination of
both in our family we have a tendency to
overthink and worry about a lot of
things so we're in the process of
hanging down a lot of debt and at the
same time we've realized a lot of our
stress comes from the fact that we have
too much stuff so we're doing our best
to get rid of a lot of stuff so you know
following Dave Ramsey and y'all's side
you know we're selling as much as we can
but we tend obsess and then I guess the
point where we get so stressed out
trying to sell stuff that we just shut
down and were like we don't know what to
do would you just give it all the way so
I guess our question is how do you kind
of balance wanting to get rid of
everything and calming down life to
really being hardcore selling stuff
paying off working extra hard you know
because both of us are moms you know we
have jobs I own my own business so to do
too much overwhelms us you know to get
to that financially stable point but
then to do nothing you know is obviously
not really great so how do you kind of
find a nice balance to both get you know
push to get to that financially stable
point but also not completely stress
yourself out with the amount of stuff
that you're doing in the process sure I
would say when you're in the process of
getting out of debt the deeper you
sacrifice the faster the progress is
gonna happen and so the more you say and
it's just a season you have kids you say
your mom - okay so the mom guilt is a
real thing and so it comes in and these
seasons really crave if I'm gonna work
overtime that means I'm not putting my
kids to bed at night right and so a lot
of that plays into the emotions and so I
want you to know that this is for a
season you're not gonna be doing this
for the next 20 years you might be doing
this for the next nine months and that
might be it right or the next 12 months
but it's not gonna be your life and so
for a short period of time the more you
can sacrifice the more progress you're
going to see and so that would be one
encouragement and yeah if you walk into
your home and you're like I don't even
know where to start and then you just
start shutting down and you just end up
on a ball on the floor right because
you're panicked just start just starts
we're just taking that next step and I
find that with a lot of people when a
lot of people start out starting to
manage their money well and they haven't
looked at bills they haven't looked at
their income statement they have no idea
anything about their financial life it
is so overwhelming but I always say take
that first step and it's amazing when
you start just even writing things down
like maybe you say ok this week we're
gonna sell 3 things and you just write
it on a sheet of paper and you just
leave it and that's it and that's all
you have to focus on because again if
it's this black hole of stuff that
you're like I don't even know where to
begin
it's gonna be tough to get started so
find a couple of things at first and
then as you start doing it whether it's
Craigslist or Ebay and you guys are
probably pros don't like how to get rid
of everything but like but really like
you know how to do it so it like in the
suspect yeah you you're gonna start to
see ok you're uncomfortable with the
process because it's not new anymore
you've already done it
and then suddenly you like ok we can
sell 5 things next week we can sell 10
things right and you can start upping
that but it's just because it's new is
what's frightening but the when you do
it once you're gonna get your feet on
your you're gonna say okay I understand
how the process works she actually
started with her tweet oh boy answer I'm
sure Jess got that about the more you
sacrifice that yeah the quicker you will
get this oh so that that's beautiful I
could I can't tell you what you should
do what your specific parameters are but
I could tell you without boundaries
you'll get nowhere and and and what I
mean by that is I had to put some
boundaries on my the things I was gonna
sell because I was also overwhelmed the
average American household has more than
300 thousand items in it that's average
so late that's not a hoarders house
that's just like everyone's house has a
bunch of stuff in it and it's not me
going around counting other people's
things that's the Los Angeles Times and
so what I could tell you is for me we're
not because I was both trying to
simplify my life and get out of debt at
the same time I put a number on it it
was mine was a relatively low number if
I could sell something for $20 or more I
would sell it if it was less than $20 I
found a way to get rid of it right away
and so I recommend a few things one is
is everything you own fits in one of
three piles
guaranteed if it's in one two three
pause it's essential it's those four the
four walls that you talked about yeah
it's sort of something you truly need in
your life right most of us need food
shelter clothing etc right and so we
have these essentials then we have the
non essentials in our life that's the
second bucket those are things that
don't we don't necessarily need but
they'd add value to our lives they
enhance our lives and make life a little
bit better right ideally that's the
those are the things that most of us
should own the most of the things
enhance our life to make life better
the third category however is what most
of us own that's junk we pretend it adds
value to our lives it has a theoretical
value there's a ton of aspirational
value in these things you bought that
outfit because it looked really good on
the mannequin but then in your closet
every time you've tried it on you're
like ah maybe next time and so it just
sits there in the the walk-in closet
full of clothes you don't enjoy wearing
it's junk it doesn't mean someone else
can't get value from it in fact they can
and they will if you let go of it so if
you can get 20 bucks for it I say sell
it if you can't get 20 bucks for I say
get rid of it really quickly get it out
of the way because it's overwhelming to
you and then set a parameter if you
can't get rid of it this week or this
month for me it was 30 days so you can
get really aggressive and say this week
for me if I couldn't get rid of it 30
days sell it then I would either lower
the price to as low as I could 20 bucks
or I would just get rid of it right now
it's even for a big electronic thing you
know if it's a TV that I thought was
worth a thousand dollars but no TVs are
actually worth a thousand dollars that
just happens to be what I paid for it
maybe I can get rid of this damn thing
for twenty dollars get it out of my life
and make some money to pay down the
debts but they don't get the things out
of my life and allow you to bring in
some money and it'll allow you to stop
you know this is the sort of
psychological torture that you're
putting yourself through yeah I would I
would say like when it comes to selling
this stuff this used to drive me crazy
because of the BlackBerry that I had
that was worth five hundred dollars when
I first got it and somehow I you know I
want to get five hundred dollars back
out of that thing when I knowing that
well so when it comes to letting stuff
ago you've got to get really comfortable
with with two words and that is some
cost you really have to understand that
a lot of this stuff you're not gonna get
what you originally paid for it in fact
you might not get anything for it and
that's okay because when you become
comfortable when I became comfortable
with sunk cost it was so much easier for
me to you know take something that has
been sitting on Craigslist for twenty
dollars that's been sitting there for
you know a month or so I can look at
that and say you know what probably not
gonna get anything out of that that is a
sunk cost I have to let go of the other
thing - oh say is when you're doing this
you can overdo anything you can overdo
minimalism you can overdo budgeting I
think really what it comes down to is do
not forsake your values and beliefs and
now I know that there are some
compromises there might be some late
nights where maybe you're coming home a
little bit later than you would like to
spend with your kids but there is a
balance between some sacrifices and
killing puppies I mean there is a middle
ground well I mean I know that's an
extreme example but but I mean that is
obviously something none of us in this
room would ever do if that if that was
getting us out of debt you know in the
next six months none of us would right
so really my short answer is is don't
kill puppies thank you so much thank you
you